welcome back to another Ocho TV episode
of tech and fails of the week
the content shown in this video has been
submitted by various players to ochodo
TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful owner
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
down to me
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
okay this is a fail
want to be featured in ochodo TV send in
your Clips by following these steps
before you submit your Clips make sure
the quality of the video is clear put
your IGN as a file name for your video
limit submissions to three to five Clips
a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your Clips on avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play Until the
End of the round next send your Clips
via Dropbox in the correct category
find it on the description of every
ochodo TV series
once you upload your video file if it
prompts you to give your name just put
in your IGN
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process thanks for
watching don't forget to hit like and be
sure to subscribe for more Tekken
content
[Music]
thank you